وحدها الصين بقيت على عهد ازمنه الاغلاق
وقيود الحركه لمنع مزيد من انتشار فيروس
كورونا
الان وقد عمه الاحتجاجات على ذلك كبرى
مدنها دعا الحزب الشيوعي الحاكم الى
التعامل بحزم مع دعوات الاحتجاج في اجتماع
لجنته السياسيه والقانونيه المركزيه شدد
الحزب على ضروره قمع ما وصفها بعمليات
التسلل والتخريب التي تقوم بها قوات
المعاديه دعا ايضا الى قمع الاعمال غير
القانونيه والاجراميه التي تخل بالنظام
الاجتماعيه وفق بيان الحزب
يشهد شارع الصيني بوادر بدء تنفيذ هذه
التوصيات فقد انتشر افراد الامن في مدينتي
بيجين وشنكاي لمنع عوده الاحتجاجات على
الاجراءات الحكوميه الصارمه لاحتواء فيروس
كورونا
يمنع هنا شرطي تصوير فحصه لهواتف احد
الماره حيث توقف الشرطه الصينيه بعضهم
للتحري بحثا عن اي محتوى او برامج مشبوهه
بما في ذلك الشبكات الافتراضيه الخاصه
التي يمكن استخدامها لتجاوز الرقابه على
الانترنت
اقيمتها على طول هذا التاريخ الذي شهد في
عطله نهايه الاسبوع تجمع عن حاسدا لرافدي
سياسات الاغلاق وصف بالاضخم منذ عقود لا
تريد السلطات مشاهد مماثله في الايام
المقبله وهنا في الحرم الرئيسي لجامعه
وبوجوههم بالكاد تظهر ملامحها يحتاج
الطلاب على تمسك الحكومه بالقيود
الاحترازيه
ذهب بعضهم الى درجه مطالبه الرئيس في جيم
بينج بلصقاله بالنسبه لبيجين لا مرد لهذه
القيود لانها تسند حسب الحكومه الصينيه
الى معطيات علميه دقيقه
اثبتت الحقائق ان اجراءات الصين بشان
فيروس كورونا تستند الى العلم وانها صحيحه
وفعاله سنواصل تنفيذ الاجراءات المستنده
الى العلم والدقه حيث نضمن الاحتواء
الفعال ونسعل دفع التنميه الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه تصر سلطات الصينيه على
الاستمرار في تطبيق
وهي سياسه تلزم الحكومات المحليه بفرض
اغلاقات عامه
واصدار اوامر بالحجر الصحي والحد من حريه
التنقل لكبح تفشل انتشار فيروس كورونا
وثارت الاحتجاجات بشانها بعد مصر 10 اشخاص
بسبب حريق شباب
يعتقد المتظاهرون ان قيود الاغلاق اعاقه
عمل فرق الانقاذ